言葉の勉強を英語の勉強は基本的にコンテンツ内容の戦略計画は鍵なんですよ
今日のビデオはどういうふうにインターネ無限のそのコンテンツの材料強化剤
どういうふうにうまく利用するかというビデオです
最初は
インターネットからどういう風にリンクに導入する
その次はそれをリっていどういう風に使うかと
ぜひあのご意見ください
リンクのインポーターが不可欠の機能
それはあのリンクのレッスンページでブラウザーエクステンションっていまして
インポートのパターンがありますそれはブラウザによって多少違いますそれをいったん
を持ちんであればですね youtube からサブタイトルな英語になる英語に
リセットしてリンクのシンボルをしてそれから自動的にいう中7 you do の
その
リリー auto そしてしゃぶタイプですがそのテキストしてレッスンとしてあの
林機に導入できますコースの名前を決めてインポートのバターンを押せば即
リンクのれ損になります微量もうそちらで見ることもできます
そしてリンクの普通の機能の知らない単語を探したり保存したりへすべての
a リンクの機能はですねええええその youtube のビデオにあの
琉舞に活用できます好きなアウター
それと普通のまあテレビ番組
フレンズだとか近いますそしてあの
デスクトップ
だけじゃなくてやはり妻方でもそれをあの勉強に利用することができますぜひこの
インポートの機能をあの使ってください
あの youtube のビデオだけじゃなくてやはり
新聞の記事も同じなんですよだからあの同じよう
いいですけどこの場合はリンクのインポートのバターン
ブラウザー1テンション
キープすれば今度省の
今の場合はニューヨークタイムズですから新しいコースを決めてそして今の新聞記事を
あの
リンクに入れることができますそして一旦
臨機に入れますと今ドリンクの普通のあの勉強の機能いろいろありますけれど
も利用できますそして自分のスマホでも同じ生地をあの勉強にですね
あのリア利用することもできますそれがもう一つのそのインポートのあの
0なんでしょあのいうて行くと新聞の記事
その他あるいは
あのあいあはしスマホからでもやはり
インポートがあのできますスマホで記事を見て
この下にやはりそのシェアのバターンありますよね
シェアもバターンを押せばそしていろんなそのシェアできるあの目的だがの出てきます
よね
そこから同じようにリンクのあのシンボルですね
リンクのインポーチんぼるを押せばこれこれと名前と同じようにあのれ村があの
りん機に導入できますそしてやはりああ
の講師も決め手そしてあの楽に
あの臨機のいわゆるパソコンでその記事を得
レッスンとして勉強することが可能になりました
で
いろんなそういうインポートのあの機能十分に利用してください
あの android でも非常に似たような機能があります
ただその
いわゆるシェアバトンの維持が多少違います
共有というところにだからそれをまあ認識知った上であの同じようにこの好きな記事と
か
スキーなその
内容を導入してそして自分のスマホで勉強することができます
だからリンクにまああの図書館に非常に豊富にたくさんの材料があるけれどもやはり
ある程度あるレブになったら自分のインターネットであの道買った思う
白いあの材料を
使うことが便利だと思います
ep 花粉ですいつも言葉の勉強についてこちらであの話してますけれども今日は一般
論じゃなくて具体的
私はどういう風に勉強しているかどういうふうにりんのシステムを使っていますそれに
ついてちょっと説明したいと思います
もちろん私は停車号と穴場語を勉強しているんですよ
ただ日本の大部分の人が英語を勉強してます
まあこちら私の
結構の事情ですよね色味にストーリーもありますし
ポンティパスもありますし a イランの人が自分についていろんな話をしてくれる
な様のようなものはありますエアー日はいつも右一人でのやりながら最も無茶しない
ようなものをやってます
だけどもだい日本人のおい
そのいわゆる学習上映そのあるよあのー
学習者が英語を勉強しています
あーちょっと今日の授業を見てみましょう
もちろん
リッ
父は映画はメイクしてないがこちらのいろんなプロ勢が
多分
雨アプリならないと思います
例えばのミニストーリー菅
まああの勉強してるあの言葉であるパ
そのブルー色の知らない看護の数
数がもと少ないんですねただ英語の
その内容が私時々
人に説明するために見てますけど勉強はしてないから
その看護がまだこのシステム
まだアテナ諌山ちー戦としては知らないとしてど
かで毎日13のですね
新しい言葉をさん
イラッ
保存しないといけないというのがたちの目的なんですよ
電車顔ではもっと高いんですよこれほんとっ以上放った
けれどもそれで
今日のビデオでお見せしたいのはですねその右し通りを中心にその web サイトの
使い方を見せした
もちろんこの言葉の勉強の時に
ミニストーリーのように振り返の多い
ギンドロたが移動しそれを同じストーリーの中に同じ構造ラジ分その単語が合意が
四回も五編も出てきますとり非常に良いわけですよ
ここはの免許あの関空方法の場合はね
私はその鍵がありましたが右飛通りで降りスレッシュ
ミニストーリーズの味0巻スタートした時でもいいし
中の時にあるいはかなり進ん
んだレベルでも
この話のその
いわゆる集中でき訓練にとってはね4
逆に対します
けどそのミリー stories 終わったらあの
インポートディスティネーションというかどちらでですね
あのいろんなブラウザーのインポート的テンションを利用してネット3 to use
のターインターネットからもういろい
その
内容を導入してその勉強材料として記憶剤として使うのが林気がつきませんの特上です
けども
今日はそれよりもその基本の技本の
その
能力を上げのためを右ストーリーについて
あの見せしたいんですよあとはですね
その具体的にその陰謀と
ねスイーツをそのいうそれをどうやるかっていうのについて
あのいわゆる説明の this ティッシュボックスにリップを入れておきます
あのーそういうふうに後興味のある方そこでもっと具体的三者どうやって
もっと面白いないよ自分にそのちょいあるないをどうやって導入して
便ですが
基本は同じです立っ
最初の愛ではニャー右人は以上ですかね
a 場合によってはチョコまでその身にじゃあつまらない
立っ
a その呉昇桓に
他の
pair
ラベたりでそれはあの日芸というレベルに設定してビギナーのもらえる
そうじゃなくてあのハイあの
nbd 1いるミリー2
豆腐風にすればフェンダーケッ
出てきますそして
読書家 podcast かニュースとか別ですもちろん皆さんが日本の形であれば
日本語の
爪が全部日本語になります私はたまたま
ブラウザは英語ですから英語ですっ
そういう水インターフェイスが英語になっています
多分皆さん日本語のいっぺースが出てく
g
内容 business ならその小説ならあの
なっアイカラーその個人持ちラベルほどできますそこから面白い
横領とテキストブレスを探すこともできます
あるいはもっとシュシュんだ段階ではシェーンずというテレビ番組とか熱リスのものも
を導入して同じ
マルーンすぐ会えることはできます
具体的にどういうその4
2それじゃあミニストーリーずにあのちょっと入ってみて
説明しますミニっ66樹ストーリア
毎日毎日の生活のまあいえば3時間ストー
一人の中に同じ合意が何回
まあ5回大体二木返されるんですよ
やっぱそれを中心にあの1月でもスカ好きでも四段に聞いたり
そういうふうにするとですねやはり
なあジグで勉強にその言葉が勉強というのはもうあれ
なれですからね
アーマー一つの
nestor もんじゃっジェリー san darmo
いうストーリー
ですよね
でエイ
インドの子ですからいっぱにーさま
亜種を機に約多いが追いそして人間
基本の原則は白いっ
ブルーよ
前に会ったことのある
しかしまだ十分人自身へないのが黄色
しかし同じ黄色
その段階がありますかだから調子ずつ何回も観て少しずつその
覚えたというのは看護というのは忘れるものです
最初わすれますもう一度見てもういいとはする
また見てまた忘れるそういう段階なん
しかし
投資ずつたくさん読んだり左
することによってだんだんど
の方います頭をな気にだから
僕の停車後アラブ語ですね始まったときに全部ブルーだったけれども今はかなりその
無知だ c pop クラスアラブ語ペルシャ語を導入しても
勉強しているときにやはり3がっ
ほとんどという白色なんですよ
だからフッコがあの黄色になったりキーが知っエア
その後ろになるのはですねー
自分でマニュアルで設定することができますし
あるいはあっ
100ページ所1ページへ行くとオフィスねプラスターありますから
rd せっつー設定することを
ますしでは何回もタダだからあれ
だんだんとぞ
その
ザンダーが早く
んですよね
a そういうようなことはですねあの全部から立派
たくさん勉強するためのあの能力者のなんですが昨日がありますけれども ok も
あります
1兄もあります
全部黒 de bain 説明することができませんけども
基本今日はね私はちょっとしさというかみなさん言いたかったのはまず
ミニストーリーの重要性それぜひしてアップ5
それから
自分の勉強のそのがいるそのどういう内容
4は勉強っていうのは文庫のルールを見てから石懸命
勉強しっていうことでその言葉を頭ならないんです慣れ慣れ慣れ慣れ
それにはあのひとつの勉強する内容の戦力
戦略だから最初ははミニストーリーが進みますそれは最初の時でもあるいは後の一つの
紛レのために
所すぎはですねやはり
そのブルー色の単語がどれぐらいあるんだ
だからでだけ10%から15%の知らない看護のものに集中した方がいい子なんですよ
やはり言葉迷宮のか濃縮ないとダメなんですよだから40%も知らない関係だったら
無理使い指数
それからじゃあ中ぐらいのものから今度次へ
もうインターネットのどこでも6
で勝利がどういう風にするのかですねぜひ
氏ディスティ富川ボックスのあのところでリンクを見てそして何か質問でもあれば是非
聴いてください
あの
皆さん楽しく万能ストールさの言葉英語の勉強ある方がの言葉でも勉強してください
じゃあ
あ釣れましたね
よくはですねあのひとつだけちょっとしてみません
あの実際の
をえっいいんですけれどもあの調べるときに
調べるときにもちろんあの自分の衣装はですね
あの
によってん
二世としてくださいもし設置算定
なかったらいいん
いいん
日本語に設定してくださいちょっと一派の106というのは色々
はあり得るけれども一番他のメンバーを選んだ
一番た前王色がこの定義ですけどだからこれが多分うーん間違えない
まあジョイ
え
しいつまでも今
ぜひ教えてくださいじゃそれで
あそれからまた興味があればあればですね
そのアイパーないし iphone で同じ
基本的に同じ操作ができますのでそれを見せることもできます
興味があります
じゃどうもみなさんさよならー
[音楽]
ん
んっ
[音楽]
pr
ん